i shouldn't
shouldn't uh shouldn't have blundered it
away
the way that i did
now i'm a little bit tilted
i have to admit that not supreme of well
the queen a4 was directed exactly
against
d5 so that i can get some initiative in
the center
so he gets one back and i'm only leading
by one now
this is a tough match i didn't lose a
single game
yesterday and today i lost three
hoping to get knight f3 and d4
eventually
yeah e5
this it's in general a bit better for me
d4 coming yeah he clearly
he primo d5 and
i don't know why he did that
no i'm just
comfortably better
we get the sort of positions that he
usually gets in the catalan where
white has some advantage in the center
94 55 okay
does he want to exchange
i guess i'm fine with this
increasing my influence in the center
further
let's go a4 trying to
pressure him in the on the queen side
not sure
where yet whether i want to go e4
and the close of this diagonal
okay a5
bishop f6 now knight g5
must be strong
that goes to f5 i have knight e4
so he decides to take it but now i have
the bishop pair for free
let's go a6 now
mess up his pawns a little bit b6 d5
i think is already it's already crushing
it's queen e5 there's bishop c6
or rookie 5 bishop b4
and the bishops really show their power
obviously this is a massive attempt at
the jinx but i think this could finally
be
uh be uh
be a good game maybe i just gave him 96
now
maybe i need to do something else like
queen a4 maybe yeah knight g6
it's a bit unfortunate
let's go queen e4 i guess
maybe bishop f4
maybe bishop f4 is the one not worried
about taking f4
crescents i will get a very strong
pawn pawn center
rook d6 also
rook a6
yeah let's go rook a6
d5 yeah i expected this
that takes takes takes
takes takes queen c46 id
attacking a6 d5 and f4
so
um
yeah let's take it and go rook d6 since
then
coordinating my pieces before i i start
grabbing more
material rooft5
yeah i don't think i'm worried about the
ending
general this should just be winning for
me
bishop d2 then f4
yeah this is just winning by now
king f2 spawns are doubled but they are
strong
and uh he's
his knight is not particularly effective
and his pawns are not going anywhere
let's go rook d7
keep the rooks for now with the
maximum central station
um
you should probably give a check
yeah let's give a check
keep his knight offside has to go to h6
h3
and now
now let's push
should be fairly
fairly comfortable now takes rookie
rooft8
e7
he has one check just not enough
okay yeah i think that was a good game